an empty lot in the northwest valley is
gaining a lot of attention from
neighbors thanks for joining us here at
six i'm denise feldas good evening i'm
brian loftis a proposed funeral home
over at tenea and lone mountain got the
green light for permits from the county
joe mueller live there with what
residents are saying about this new idea
joe
hey there guys yeah this is the lot
behind me here that they are where they
want to build this funeral home it's in
a very residential area of lone mountain
but if we take a look just across the
street just south of this lot there's a
cemetery that's actually owned by the
same company that wants to build this
funeral home well neighbors who live
around this area say they like how
residential it is and they want to keep
it that way
please respect that we live there we've
lived there for years and we don't want
this a funeral home isn't exactly the
neighbor people were expecting to get in
this area of lone mountain call it what
you will this is a commercial business
and is not permitted the bunkers group
wants to build this funeral home
managing partner larry davis says the
company already owns another funeral
home in town and the cemetery at the
same intersection one of the things that
i i felt that we needed was to have a
funeral home that was
in proximity to
our cemetery county commissioners voted
to approve the use permit for the
project i live in a neighborhood where
i would have much rather had a funeral
or cemetery as opposed to the three
schools that i got resident bridget
solvey says she is worried about how it
will change the residential feel this is
a commercial project that is not on the
cemetery property this is on a parcel in
a neighborhood that was plotted in 1950.
davis says he believes this location
will not damage the area but improve it
i do believe it's a good location for
number one because right across the
street from our cemetery
and
because of the families that we do serve
he says the company hopes to break
ground within a year standby
another concern that many residents
expressed was whether or not cremations
will be happening here at this location
if their funeral home is built uh the
developer davis says that there is going
to be no crematory reporting live in low
mountain joe mohler live local now